this may be about to get cheaper in the
biggest shake-up of britain's pub
industry in centuries politicians have
voted to scrap the so-called beer time
the current situation sees 13 000
tenants of pubs being tied to the
company that owns the pub providing them
with all of their drinks and having the
ability to set the cost at which those
drinks are supplied unilaterally
it meant some landlords paid premiums of
up to eighty percent on a wholesale keg
of lager
now they'll be able to shop around for
the best beer deals this legislation
should revitalize
part of the pub industry uh it will
provide a fair deal for
republicans
and it uh should actually provide a
saving for people using pubs
the change hasn't gone down well with
the big brewers they claim it could lead
to the closure of 1400 pubs and the loss
of 7 000 jobs depending on where you
stand then the future of britain's pubs
is either glass half full or glass half
empty